now joining us now with the reaction the
upcoming book but we're not gonna talk
about it now
June 5th barnesandnoble.com you can
pre-order it's on Hanna's this is like
your daily daily torture I just get nude
out here and well make sure we don't
talk about his new book no but I have
what we're gonna do an hour of my radio
show and we're gonna do an hour special
but let me go back to a Russian saying
because I think this is so funny he's a
genius but yes he's short an absolute
genius but I said I got in a little bit
last night with Laura because Laura
showed me the clapper stuff when the
point where clapper talked about he
didn't he doesn't like talking about
spying they couldn't help myself I said
he was the Director of National
Intelligence he was in charge of every
spy we have what how can you have a
Director of National Intelligence who
doesn't like spying I mean you could
just the whole thing's crazy all right
as Russia's brilliant you're one of the
smartest people I know yeah but it's a
very small circle okay okay we've known
each other a long time but here's where
we are
Hillary commits felonies obstructs
justice you know the the leading the
acid washing then we gotta cover it up
and rigged investigation writing an
exoneration months before they interview
her seventeen others then on top of what
we have an unmasking problem now we
learn we've got spies in the campaign we
have FISA judges lied to on a Hillary
Clinton bought and paid for dossier that
the own author said in an interrogatory
oh that was raw intelligence maybe 50/50
that became the basis to get FISA
warrant and three subsequent renewals
this to me tell me if I'm wrong is the
biggest corruption abuse of power we've
ever seen
oh by a huge margin and then I talked
about this one day when I think on the
radio show we really need to figure out
how to physically show this you have the
Clinton corruption going on back for
many many years I think all the way back
to cattle futures where the Wall Street
Journal figured out it was
mathematically impossible for her to
have made that much money honestly
so they've been used to getting away
with things for since 1979 1980
then you have the people who covered up
for her corruption and I'm counting in
the whole thing with with the emails as
part of the corruption so that's a
second layer then you have the fear that
oh my god
Trump could win and now you have a third
layer which is how do we get the very
people who are protecting her Andy
McCarthy had a wonderful line he said
great he said he wrote he wrote
Democrats get away with murder and
Republicans get murdered and that that's
the current justice but so but dying it
that way no but now here's the new layer
that I began to realize in the last
three days all of a sudden all these
guys who plan to bask and corruption are
beginning to realize that they in fact
could be indicted and convicted in clap
i've known clapper for years clapper
used to be a serious professional the
guy I see on TV now is pathetic what
about Brennan well no Brennan was a
member of the Communist Party of the USA
only Obama would pick an explicit
communist to be the head of the CIA I
mean you know I'm not sure who he
thought Brennan would protect from who
but here's the point
Brennan now has this problem Comey has
this problem NAB has this problem
clapper has this problem and all the
sudden these dead Lynch has this problem
the truth is you're gonna find out
pretty soon those right into the White
House there's no doubt I have zero that
I have not Barack Obama not knowing this
if we do if the truth comes out it will
go right to the Obama White House that's
right and Jared and rice and power and
Ben Rhodes and the rest of them I mean
just given the way they ran a very tight
operation they know does anybody believe
the Valerie Jarrett didn't know this
stuff remember they gave away the New
York Times trying to do catch up which I
felt was kind of well vindication in a
way but in another way they just try to
spin it but they revealed very early on
when that trip took place to Great
Britain that in fact there were deep
negotiations with downer with our state
department that had to be at the top for
him to allow himself to be interviewed
by the FBI
you see straight going down this list
and then get this guy that we've now
sort of identified as not identified no
it's baloney who apparently got like
over a million dollars over the years
from the deep state yep two years yeah
and so you start saying oh so it's okay
and and what I read was entrapment I
mean he's he's saying this guy that's
what Victoria tensing just said yeah
yeah he's saying this guy oh come on you
really tell giving him me give me well
and the guy he says even a human ain't
nothing there are you confident because
Hillary wins none of this comes out are
you confident we have the ability to get
to the truth completely no neither am i
and what it's what it's going to come
down to is whether or not the president
can keep focused he is he is now but
this is gonna go on for two or three
years but they're setting traps for him
left and right for him to get mad and
fire but not just that
I mean digging this stuff out making the
connections where's Jeff Sessions doing
what wrong with him
well I think if we had an attorney
general we do Rob Rosenstein well the
Rosen sign is I think your case is right
i I am so saddened by Jeff Sessions in a
bill I don't know what happened to him
but his hair ability to do his job
scary again he's a guy I've liked a long
time he took and he just folded we will
I will have haha radio and TV great this
thing's good every to see you and I will
hold you to that